so I really want to start with
congratulations on this you're both
fantastic in this movie uh but I like
throwing a curveball at the beginning so
um I'm curious like everyone thinks they
probably know something about the way it
is in Hollywood being an actor what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about being an actor in
Hollywood that's a good question because
people do know a lot they know a lot I I
think that um I I don't I don't know I
feel like sometimes it's hard to
describe the pleasure that you get in
simply doing the work on set you know I
think that that's I think people see a
lot of stuff about the business I think
when they you think about like being an
actor in Hollywood you know there's a
lot of information about like um the
size of movies and and locations and
costumes and all of that kind of a lot
of physical things about production but
but the thing that I love the most and I
think that people don't understand is
like the sense of play that you have
when you're doing something how much fun
it is how how hard you laugh how silly
things are how basic it is it's like a
and it's a very it's very
like um I don't know it's like you know
you're you're eating lunch in a parking
lot you're getting your makeup in a
trailer you're the sun is shining in
your eyes you you know you have to be
wrapped before the sun goes down there
there's a lot of kind of physicality to
it um wrapped up with like the the fun
you're just like
pretending that's a good yeah that's a
really nice thing I was I was like
thinking of like much shallower things
were you like let just spend hours of
your life in makeup she's shallow I'm
shallow she's the Deep
one thank you thank you that's all I
ever
wanted I will jump into I get talk to
you guys one of the things I watch a lot
of movies and one of the things I love
about this m movie one of the many
things is that I never could predict
what the next scene was going to be
right I also love how the script never
demonizes anyone it it never judges so
can you both talk about the script and
honestly how good it is it's so good I
mean it's really hard to believe that
it's Sammy bur's first script yeah um
that she wrote on spec I think it's um
there's so many brilliant choices and
there's so much like
unspoken conflict and drama in the
scenes that some times would reveal
itself to me while we were doing it like
I would think oh this is like a tiny
little scene and then we'd start saying
it and I was like oh there's all these
lines that have almost been erased in
here like all of the everything's
between the lines it's so well written
um and there's amazing things that she
brought into it like I I felt like her
Casting experience before the casting
scenes like that's that's like uh
something that's so kind of wicked and
in the script um the the casting of the
boys of young Joe and I think only she
could have you know conjured that up
yeah it was it was deceptively simple
the language that was that was the thing
and then and then I said to Sammy too
when you get into it it's like really
muscular it could hold a lot a lot of
feeling and a lot of humor and and and
it would be and sometimes the language
when we would say it to one another you
realize how challenging it was that one
character was kind of Challen ing
another but it didn't seem that way on
the page it just when it came out of
your mouth you'd be like
whoa the other thing about this which
most people won't realize is you didn't
have a lot of time to shoot this I want
to say it was like 23 days or something
like that as an actor do you enjoy that
pressure of knowing I might only have
two takes I have to nail this or is it
you know what I mean because it's so
different than if you're making a bigger
film well I think when you have a
director as as prepared and precise and
Visionary as Todd is that
you can feel comfortable in that
scenario and then it just becomes fun
like you're all just like in it and the
Train's going and you're just like
everyone's on their aame and like you're
saying you know has to kind of execute
to to make make it work um and he's such
a great leader for that because he
really gets everyone on the same page
and and knows exactly what he's going to
do and is so professional and on it
because you can't you can't be anything
but um and and then he's just like the
most
genuine kind loving um and and just a
beautiful artist so it's it's like when
you're in those hands you can kind of do
anything is there anything you want to
add yeah you always want more time but
you know it's like they say in preschool
you get what you get you don't get upset
you're just
like like well you know here we go but
but it's true I think I think people
knowing that that's what it was and that
we had to be prepared and Todd was so
prepared um that just makes you you're
like well okay we're we're ready we're
just we're just going to figure this out
you know um so yeah and T's also very
joyful you know he he laughs I mean
that's the other thing too you can
always hear him laughing um and and when
he does laugh you know that he's he's
getting what he wants you know so it's
it's very encouraging like I said
earlier I'm a big fan of both of your
work and you guys have done such
tremendous work through your careers I'm
just curious with the previous projects
you've worked on what do you think was
the one that before you stepped on said
I'm really nervous about this like on a
level that is not usual for me oh I'm
like all of oh I'm always nervous I'm
always nervous I'm always terrified
yeah um I think Jackie was especially
scary for me because it was a real very
well-known person so I was like oh boy
like if this is a fail this is the
biggest fail cuz like everyone will
recognize it it's not like you can be
like I'm you know making it up you know
you're really you know comparing
yourself to something that's very
someone who's very well documented that
was scary that was the hardest probably
but I'm always scared I'm always scared
too I was scared right before we were
doing this I actually called Todd I was
like I don't think I can do this this is
way harder than I thought but I but I
think I think the worst thing for me was
having to sing in dear EV which I really
wanted to do I love that song and I
really wanted to sing it but I thought I
would swallow my tongue I was so scared
I was like I'm going to choke I
literally going to choke on my own
saliva in the middle of this it was so
you did it live yeah we did it live I
was like why are we doing this live this
is a
movie I I got I have to rap but I have
to say I'm a big fan of that movie and I
still can't believe what Ben does in
terms of the singing and the crying at
the same time
beautiful beautiful singer that voice is
just like magic and his ease when he
sings and his access to his emotions I
just admire him so much it's beautiful
beautiful I agree congratulations on
this thank you for giving me your time
good luck with the rest of your speed
day than thank you what it's
like